[Musica]
questo mio padre mio padre è nato nel
1944 uomo di formazione classica per
quasi 50 anni è stato uno straordinario
notaio in una piccola città di provincia
in molise a termoli per quasi 50 anni il
lavoro di mio padre ha avuto una vasta
gamma di operazioni che lo tenevano
impegnato alcune delle quali francamente
ripetitive quasi meccaniche per esempio
quando mio padre costituisce una società
semplice tipo una srl semplificata suo
lavoro sembra essere un insieme di
operazioni una lista di operazione il
suo lavoro è quella di assicurarsi che
le operazioni vengono compiute nel
giusto ordine e lui è lì a vidimare che
tutto avvenga secondo i crismi del caso
però questa è la parte noiosa della loro
il mio padre
in realtà il lavoro di mio padre è molto
più complesso e in una serie di casi si
occupava di riconciliare sostanzialmente
l'universale con il particolare in un
caso come ad esempio non so la divisione
di un'eredità in assenza di indicazioni
testamentarie chiare il lavoro il mio
padre era aver a che fare ha veramente
qualcosa di universale come il quadro
normativo di riferimento nelle gi
sull'eredità e poi coniugare questo in
un contesto molto preciso unico ed
irripetibile che sono le persone
coinvolte a chi sono le persone che
devono spartirsi l'eredità c'è
dell'animosità fra di loro o invece si
vogliono bene
la somma in questione una somma che può
cambiare loro la vita o è una somma di
cui possono fare a meno sono avidi o non
si curano delle cose materiali qual era
il loro rapporto con il defunto e così
via
tutto questo in particolare è
assolutamente irripetibile e il suo
lavoro e mettere insieme sostanzialmente
questo che accade qui con quello che noi
teniamo in generale per tutti i casi
possibili quindi fondamentalmente per 50
anni il lavoro di mio padre è stato
quello di esercitare una delle più
sublimi facoltà degli esseri umani
il giudizio complesso
l'intelligenza artificiale oggi per
larga parte si occupa di costruire
algoritmi quindi sistemi artificiali che
automatizzano alcuni dei nostri lavori
intellettuali
siamo uno dei casi più semplici e più
utilizzati il riconoscimento di immagini
cioè allenare un algoritmo a riconoscere
cosa è rappresentato all'interno di
un'immagine per esempio ne possiamo
avere un algoritmo che prende impasto
qualunque foto e cui unico scopo è dirci
se questa foto rappresenta un gatto
oppure no qualcosa del genere a
algoritmi di questo tipo voi utilizzate
tutti i giorni in continuazione a questo
è una foto del mio google foto come
vedete google organizza le mie foto in
cose persone e posti milano mai detto
google di fare questa cosa che in
qualche modo ha imparato che alcune
delle mie foto rappresentano delle
persone alcune delle foto rappresentano
invece dei luoghi e le organizza
automaticamente un altro caso che avete
presente sicuramente quando facebook
riconosce il volto di una persona che è
nel vostro network e vi suggerisce di
taggarlo ok da capo nessuno ha spiegato
è letteralmente facebook chi è questa
persona ma un algoritmo di
riconoscimento visivo riconosce questo
volto
allora ci sono due cose da tenere a
mente a mio avviso di come funzionano
questi sistemi
ok perché danno un'idea di quale il
framework di riferimento di qual è il
modo in cui abbiamo pensato
sostanzialmente all'applicazione
d'intelligenza artificiale
il primo è che in nessuno di questi casi
la maggior parte di queste di queste
applicazioni sono rese possibili da
algoritmi di intelligenza artificiale
nel caso di fattispecie di machine
learning
io ho fatto uno sforzo titanico per
tradurre tutto per questo talk machine
learning non ci sono riuscito ma cile
ronnie significa sostanzialmente un
algoritmo che impara quindi la cosa che
dobbiamo tenere a mente in questo caso è
semplice non dobbiamo programmare una
macchina nei dettagli per riconoscere un
gatto
dobbiamo dargli un'indicazione di
massima che voglio capire se questa
immagine rappresenta un gatto e poi gli
dobbiamo dare dei dati tanti dati dati
da cui deve imparare specificamente
funziona così
noi prendiamo tante immagini
alcune di gatti alcune di noi e le
etichettiamo a mano
c'è una persona che lo fa elettrica atti
gatto se c'è un gatto e non gatto se non
c'è un gatto si danno tutte queste
immagini impasto all'algoritmo è
l'algoritmo impara da solo
quali sono le caratteristiche delle
immagini che costituiscono un predittore
statistico efficace per poterci dire
quando l'algoritmo vedrà un'immagine che
non ha mai visto prima
secondo me quest'immagine un gatto
quindi la cosa tenere a mente che non
dobbiamo davvero programmarli imparano
da sempre secondo punto che è molto
importante air questi algoritmi non
hanno bisogno di sapere fondamentalmente
nulla del mondo che non devono sapere
cos'è un gatto da nessuna parte nella
rappresentazione dell'algoritmo non c'è
uno stato della macchina in cui non
avremmo il concetto di gatto
ogni stato della macchina è matrice di
numeri qualcosa come quella che vedete
sullo schermo completamente
incomprensibile un essere umano è
fondamentalmente l'idea che l'algoritmo
deve semplicemente sapere data una nuova
immagine quanto è vicina la predizione
che sta facendo
relativamente a se questa immagine
rappresenti un gatto no
rispetto a tutte le immagini che ha
visto in passato non c'è bisogno di
sapere niente dei gatti non c'è bisogno
di sapere che sono mammiferi quadrupedi
che hanno una coda che hanno le orecchie
che fanno le fusa che prendono i topi
che tipicamente sono più piccole dei
cani ma a volte ci sono delle eccezioni
niente quindi tutti i concetti che
invece un essere umano esprimerebbe
qualora noi dovessimo chiedergli ma come
fai a riconoscere un gatto questi
algoritmi non hanno bisogno di saperli e
questo è un vantaggio enorme perché
significa che quando noi dobbiamo
mettere in produzione questi algoritmi
quando noi dobbiamo utilizzarle davvero
a possiamo evitare di perdere tempo in
domande complicate tipo qual è la
rappresentazione concettuale di un gatto
ma basta che noi abbiamo abbastanza
immagini di gatti è un algoritmo
benfatto un'indicazione di massima e
possiamo aspettarci che non posso
imparare a fare un lavoro ottimo una
volta migliore di quello degli esseri
umani
il punto è che l'intelligenza
artificiale adesso come adesso è
letteralmente una rivoluzione è davvero
in tutti i device che utilizziamo in
molti in tutte le applicazioni della
nostra vita quotidiana e lo sarà sempre
di più
alcuni l'hanno paragonato
all'elettricità no
però questo modo di pensare che è quello
che ha reso di fatto possibile che
l'intelligenza artificiale diventasse
così presente nei prodotti che
utilizziamo anche dei delle
controindicazioni o comunque diciamo
solleva delle preoccupazioni una delle
conseguenze di questo approccio è per
esempio il fatto che noi abbiamo bisogno
di un sacco di dati perché
fondamentalmente dobbiamo allenare gli
algoritmi a capire come funzionano le
cose con tanti dati questo è il motivo
per cui sentite parlare sempre di big
data
questo il motivo per cui si dice che i
dati sono il nuovo petrolio
il problema è non tutti hanno la stessa
quantità di dati non tutti sono google
non tutti sono amazon non tutti sono gli
stati uniti d'america che alcune entità
hanno tanti dati al 30 non ce le hanno
per natura
il secondo problema è che siccome
l'algoritmo non ha una rappresentazione
concettuale simile a quella che abbiamo
noi da nessuna parte
finisce che l'algoritmo è un po una
scatola nera cioè ogni volta che io apro
algoritmo oa delle matrici di dati che
sono numero incomprensibili per un
essere umano
il problema di questo approccio è che
quando le cose vanno storte è complicato
sapere perché e quindi la domanda che
dovremmo porci probabilmente quali dei
lavori intellettuali che stiamo in
qualche modo automatizzando con
intelligenza artificiale sono adatti a
questo approccio per esempio se
dovessimo creare una versione
artificiale di mio padre cioè un notaio
artificiale
noi saremmo a nostro agio con l'idea che
un algoritmo che non ha il concerto di
diritto che non ha il concetto di legge
che non ha il concetto di cittadino si
prenda la briga di costituire una srl
semplificata magari sì alla fine
sembrerebbe che costituirono essere alle
semplificata se non ci sono eccezioni è
un lavoro abbastanza semplice abbastanza
meccanico ma saremo altrettanto nostro
agio con l'idea che questo algoritmo che
di nuovo non sa vedere diritto non
all'idea di legge non ha l'idea di
cittadino che questo algoritmo si prende
la briga di prendere delle decisioni su
un caso molto più complesso come la
divisione di un'eredità in caso di
vaghe indicazioni testamentarie ne
parliamo
comincia a diventare una domanda vera
quindi la questione diciamo è esiste un
modo di pensare l'intelligenza
artificiale che può essere alternativo a
questo o in qualche modo vada nella
direzione di avvicinare un pochino
quello che gli s il processo mentale che
fanno gli esseri umani quando compiono
delle operazioni intellettuali e le
macchine a soprattutto perché noi
sappiamo che esiste un caso del genere
sappiamo che esistono dei casi del
genere in natura che esistono dei casi
in cui l'intelligenza l'apprendimento
avvengono in modo diverso lo sappiamo
perché abbiamo dei figli e vediamo come
funzionano i bambini io nella mia vita
ho fatto su cui lavoro estranei uno di
questi gara linguista e questo è uno dei
casi che ad esempio è un qualche modo è
un puzzle per i linguisti cioè io posso
spiegare un bambino che camminare st un
uomo come striscia restava un serpente
letteralmente con tre esempi non mi
serve fargli vedere un milione di esempi
o terabyte di dati
questo semplice equazione che sembra
semplice ma che in realtà credetemi se
bisogna insegnare a una macchina è molto
complicata perché richiede anche un
livello di astrazione per cui si capisce
che appunto camminare è la stessa cosa
per un serpente nonostante le due cose
apparentemente sono diverse cioè livello
superficiale sono effettivamente i
movimenti diversi pattern di movimenti
diversi
tutto questo ha un bambino io lo posso
spiegare rapidamente quindi cosa c'era
l'intelligenza del bambino che manca nel
tipo di algoritmi che vi ho fatto vedere
prima cosa sa di quale superpotere del
bambino in questo caso una delle idee
più sensate a riguardo è che
semplicemente il bambino abbia i
concerti il termine tecnico è un modello
generativo concettuale ma
fondamentalmente l'idea è questa noi
possiamo pensare ai concerti come a le
istruzioni dell'ego quindi noi abbiamo
dei piccoli concerti che noi possiamo
montare insieme quando li montiamo
insieme creano dei concerti più
complessi e così via
e abbiamo una mappa di quali sono
abbiamo i nostri pezzi nostri concetti
fondamentali poi abbiamo le istruzioni
per monti
insieme questo ci consente di andare dal
particolare all'universale quindi al
semplice al complesso e dal complesso al
semplice e questo consente al bambino di
farlo in un modo che è esattamente
quello che il nostro algoritmo sembra
non essere in grado di fare cioè con
pochi dati e potendo ricostruire quali
pezzi ha messo insieme e quando e come e
quindi può rendere merito del
ragionamento che c'è stato per giungere
ad una determinata conclusione per
esempio nel caso di fattispecie noi
potremmo pensare che nella
rappresentazione mentale del bambino di
essere vivente c'è un posto speciale per
come gli esseri viventi deambulano se
deambulano e quindi in questo posto
speciale noi sappiamo che meglio il
bambino sa che questo posto è occupato
da camminare per gli esseri umani è
occupato da strisciare per i serpenti
che significa che il bambino a questo
punto è consapevole del fatto che
camminare si applica solo agli uomini e
strisciare solo i serpenti sono diversi
ma che ha un livello di astrazione
superiore queste due cose sono
fondamentalmente la stessa cosa
sono due modi di deambulare quindi la
questione di come funziona un sistema
concettuale più biologico è che
sembrerebbe essere in grado di risolvere
un po di problemi che avremmo invece con
intelligenza artificiale cioè può
imparare con pochi dati e può essere in
grado di essere aperto e comunicato
quindi in un mondo in cui noi
effettivamente abbiamo intenzione di
utilizzare l'intelligenza artificiale in
un sacco di ambiti perché ci rende la
vita migliore
alcuni di questi ambiti sono ambiti
complessi mercati finanziari le
assicurazioni la sanità la legge la
domanda è
vogliamo un intelligenza artificiale che
sia così difficile da interpretare
o c'è un valore nel pensare
l'intelligenza artificiale in modo
diciamo più orientata agli esseri umani
e al tipo di pensiero che gli esseri
umani intrattengono perché a mio avviso
se noi costruiamo sistemi di
intelligenza artificiale ispirati a
quello che sappiamo dei questi processi
più biologici si aprono delle
possibilità molto interessanti che al
momento sono solo in nuce ha per esempio
potremmo cominciare a pensare ad un
mondo in cui le capacità
dell'intelligenza artificiale non sono
più
da pannaggio solo di poche
organizzazioni governi o company che
hanno la quantità di dati necessaria per
per dispiegare queste capacità su scala
ma magari diventano qualcosa di cui
possono approfittare anche altre entità
che hanno per loro natura meno dati nel
nostro piccolo io i miei colleghi per
anni ci siamo occupati fondamentalmente
di questo noi l'abbiamo applicata
all'ambito dell'e commerce
il nostro problema specifico era che
sapete insomma nell'e commerce
sostanzialmente c'è amazon che funziona
molto bene e gli altri più o meno amazon
può contare sul fatto però che
sostanzialmente macina più dati di tutti
gli altri messi insieme e l'anno
prossimo ne macinerà di più e l'anno
dopo ancora ancora di più il suo
vantaggio competitivo non solo adesso
incolmabile ma tende a diventare ancora
più incolmabile nel tempo e le altre
aziende hanno comunque bisogno delle
capacità di amazon perché i loro clienti
sono gli stessi clienti di amazon
siamo noi noi ci siamo abituati al fatto
che amazon si ricorda chi sono
mi fai suggerimenti dei dei prodotti
giusti eccetera eccetera e gli altri
come fanno gli altri che non hanno
abbastanza dati quello che noi abbiamo
fatto sostanzialmente lavorare con
l'idea che i sistemi potevano essere
costruiti su ispirazione biologica per
aggirare questo problema perché anche
queste altre aziende avevano bisogno di
queste capacità ma non potevamo contare
sul fatto che avrebbero mai generato
abbastanza dati per poterlo fare nello
stesso modo in cui lo fanno amazon
google huber e i grandi grandi colossi
della tecnologia a noi l'abbiamo
applicatori commerce ma ovviamente il
punto è il limite il cielo
noi possiamo applicarlo possiamo avere
approcci di questo genere in sanità i
mercati finanziari nelle nostre
assicurazioni casi della legge per
esempio ha quindi sostanzialmente credo
che la domanda più generale su cui vale
la pena interrogarsi e non c'è una
risposta che sta una domanda nuova per
il genere umano
onestamente nessuno una risposta è
quanto siamo confortevole con l'idea di
un mondo in cui solo poche
organizzazioni e pochi governi e pochi
enti hanno la possibilità di dispiegare
cosa così importante e così potente su
scala e quanto invece vogliamo un mondo
in cui le capacità di intelligenza
artificiale gli esseri umani in qualche
modo vivano un pochino più in armonia
perché in realtà è uso le parole di uno
dei miei autori preferiti jaron lanier
quando gli sviluppatori di tecnologie
digitali disegnano un programma di
richiedono di interagire con un computer
come se il computer fosse una persona e
al contempo in qualche modo vi chiedono
di accettare in un angolo della vostra
mente l'idea che voi a vostra volta
siate dei programmi e io non credo che
ci sia niente di male in questo
nell'equazione fra le macchine e le
persone di per sé filosoficamente purché
ci poniamo tutti la domanda di come
andare in una direzione verso la quale
uomini e macchine si assomigliano di più
una direzione in cui magari progettiamo
più macchine che somiglino a mio padre
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]